[Musique]
on n'y comprend rien à rien jolie
personne ne veut rien comprendre
moi j'ai assisté d'abord ça a commencé
dans la chute dans sa chambre du coup je
dors avec elle et j'ai ça a commencé par
des débris qui volaient ont été arrosés
chacun à son tour le tiroir d'une petite
table de nuit qui a volé à plusieurs
reprises toujours dans sa direction des
objets religieux aussi ça doit la vision
du tout et ça les femmes vierges de
notre dame de lourdes christ
bah moi ma cousine vertueux un christ
dans le dos moi j'ai reçu une sainte
vierge dans la figure et sans savoir
exactement d'où ça venait et les traces
d'ecchymoses que vous portez sur la
figure et bien moi je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce que
vous ne vous rappelez pas moi vous êtes
fait ça vous vous êtes fait ça ou bien
ceux ci avait chargé à beignon qu'est ce
que c'est qu'il m'a blessé il enseigne
c'est une casserole il mardi soir je me
trouvais ici avec mon mari
la grand mère en question là se trouvait
à table avec le jeune homme et puis il
ya une assiette une fourchette qui était
dans un plat qui a jailli et puis s'est
retrouvé sur la tête d'un de mes amis
qui se trouvaient à cuisine la plus la
fourchette varie l'a fait l'approché de
la tête comme ça oui simplement pas bien
la fourchette a traversé toute la bande
est traversé à la fourchette a disparu
du plat et s'est retrouvé sur la tête
l'appareil un nul on voit pas de chose
partir on va pas l'objet disparaître
comme ça c'est le sens qu'il arrive que
[Musique]
y est haut dans la chambre patrick et
avait mois elle est de cadrer son quai
sadali mois sans bouger sinon à l'envi
et ja je ressens plus rien du tout
que ça y est ça nito seules ils savent
où me lama au lendemain matin 104
saifullah santucci sans rien du tout ni
qu'on a rien rien rien en tout cas j'ai
la conscience tranquille c'est tout ce
que je peux vous dire ça c'est bien
tranquille à ce sujet là rien fait
monsieur le curé venu vous trouvez aussi
il est venu bénir la maison oui oui
quand on s'est cachés
alors monsieur le curé que s'est il
passé exactement pour moi et bien des
choses tandis que extraordinaire dans ce
sens qu'elles sortent de l'ordinaire
mais je ne veux pas me prononcer
absolument pas avant demain
vendredi après midi en la personne
j'ai acquis j'ai dû faire des marques
qui viennent
mais quoi vous pensé lorsque lorsque
vous dites ça au diable sans doute non
et à écouter quiche équipe aime bien les
sottises
vous êtes venu venir la maison le riz
est que c'est arrivé une aventure je
prends ah oui mais c'est là je je ne
veux pas raconter ça dans les détails
avant de mari
qu'elle mâche un
statut qui
[Musique]
nous allons nous coucher on a tous nous
avons trouvé un lapin sur le lit ici est
un autre
et celui qui était donc sur mon lit ça
où j'ai couche
n'a pas bougé
et l'autre est parti et il restait un
petit moment enfin la plus jamais
retrouvé donc tu suis a passé toute la
nuit blanche comme nous il insisté
disant s'il pouvait parler à tout le
reste ce cinéma cirque quoi
une hypothèse une hypothèse
[Musique]
ce sont des forces occultes